(ENRIQUE)
Alemania es ese país
que siempre suele aparecer en los mejores
puestos de los rankings de productividad,
calidad de vida y desarrollo humano. La mayor
potencia económica es vista por muchos políticos,
analistas y expertos de todo tipo
como un auténtico modelo a seguir.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, amigas de
VisualPolitik, en los últimos tiempos,
son otras las noticias que está acaparando
cada vez más titulares. Nos referimos
exactamente a cosas como estas:
N1 (21 de abril de 2023: BERLÍN:
Aumenta la delincuencia en la capital
alemana tras la pandemia. The Local)
(4 de noviembre de 2023: la policía alemana pide
zonas libres de cuchillos en las ciudades. DW)
N3 (27 de noviembre de 2023: Mucha
delincuencia, muy poco personal:
el jefe de policía de Bremen da la alarma. El
aumento de los robos y los robos de vehículos
es especialmente dramático. Butenunbinnen)
Ya lo veis, por increíble que nos pueda parezca,
lo cierto es que Alemania está hoy atravesando un
fortísimo repunte en sus cifras
de delitos y crímenes violentos.
No importa que este tipo de problemas se
suelan asociar a tasas de pobreza altas,
elevados niveles de marginalidad o fHalta
de cuerpos de seguridad. Alemania, uno de
los países más ricos y desarrollados
de todo el mundo, no tiene ninguno de
esos problemas y pese a ello las cifras de
criminalidad se están disparando de repente.
Según los datos oficiales, de la propia policía,
el país se enfrenta a una incipiente ola de robos,
asesinatos, delitos sexuales y
tráfico de personas. En este campo,
Alemania está experimentando su peor
momento de por lo menos la última década.
Ahora bien, puede que te estés haciendo una
pregunta: pero… Enrique, ¿Alemania? ¿De verdad?
Yo lo había escuchado, era precisamente
todo lo contrario de la poderosa Alemania.
Pues… ¿Sabéis qué? No me extraña. Hasta hace no
mucho la situación era muy distinta. De hecho,
tan recientemente como en 2019, la situación
era exactamente la contraria. Por aquel tiempo,
la verdad, no tan lejano, Alemania sacaba pecho:
N4 (8 de mayo de 2018: Alemania registra la tasa
de criminalidad más baja desde 1992. Politico)
N5 (4 de febrero de 2019: La tasa
de criminalidad en Alemania cae
a su nivel más bajo en décadas. DW)
Pero… Entonces, ¿qué explica semejante
cambio? ¿Qué demonios está pasando con el crimen
en Alemania? ¿Qué diantres explica
esta ola de violencia e inseguridad?
Pues, queridos amigos, amigas, estas
son las preguntas que nos hemos hecho
en VisualPolitik. Preguntas que
vamos a responder en este vídeo.
Gasolina y arranquemos.
[Pero antes, ¿eres consciente de
todo lo que te estás perdiendo por
no usar Surfshark, nuestro patrocinador de hoy?
Lo más importante de todo: la seguridad.
Con Surfshark tus movimientos en internet
estarán fuertemente protegidos, cifrados y a
salvo de ojos curiosos. Además, con CleanWeb,
se acabarán los anuncios intrusivos y el
malware. Y eso no es todo. Con Surfshark
Alert también te enterarás al instante si
tu información personal ha sido filtrada.
Pero, ¡aún hay más! Surfshark es la
primera VPN comercial con servidores
en más de un centenar de países. Algo
así como un pasaporte global a golpe
de click con el que podrás acceder a
contenidos bloqueados por ubicación.
Y si te preocupa tener que elegir en qué
dispositivo usarlo, tranquilo. Con la misma
cuenta, puedes proteger todos tus dispositivos,
ya sea tu móvil, tu tablet, el ordenador,
la tele o tu consola, ¡sin límites! De hecho, si
quieres ahorrar al máximo, puedes compartir la
cuenta con tus mejores amigos. Así, entre todos,
pagaréis unos pocos céntimos al mes cada uno.
Lo mejor de todo: por ser parte de la comunidad
VisualPolitik puedes disfrutar de HASTA SEIS
MESES EXTRA totalmente gratis usando el código
“POLITIK”. Os dejamos el link en la descripción
Y dicho esto, ¡continuemos
con nuestro video de hoy!
si hablamos de historia, creo que está claro
que alemania es un país que da para todo.
2 guerras mundiales, el muro de Berlín, la
creación de la unión europea y muchísimo más.
pero amigos, hay un periodo muy importante que se
suele pasar por alto, pero que cambió a alemania
en términos económicos: la reunificación.
veréis, cuando el muro de Berlín cayó,
la parte comunista de alemania tuvo
que adaptarse de golpe al capitalismo.
eso supuso que de la noche a la mañana, muchas
empresas públicas del este tuvieron que cerrar,
el desempleo se disparó, aumentaron los
niveles de pobreza en el corto plazo,
y la desigualdad entre este y oeste empezó
a provocar enormes conflictos sociales.
para colmo, la policía de la Alemania oriental,
estaba especializada en el control social,
la censura y la represión política. así que
tuvo que ser remodelada de arriba abajo. no
solo a nivel operativo sino también cultural.
¿el resultado? pues como os podéis imaginar
un panorama particularmente propenso
a la proliferación del crimen.
por supuesto, con el tiempo
la situación fue mejorando,
la liberalización del este impulsó su economía,
y al mismo tiempo el gobierno federal regó con
dinero público las zonas marginales excomunistas.
esa mejora luego se tradujo en una reducción de
las tasas de criminalidad, y de esta forma,
Alemania mejoró su nivel de seguridad hasta
situarse prácticamente en el promedio europeo.
mejor incluso que países como Francia.
sin embargo, el repunte de la delincuencia
que se está produciendo ahora es
una situación completamente diferente.
(T1: ACLARANDO LOS NÚMEROS)
Pero antes de meternos de lleno en materia
tenemos que tener cuenta unas cuantas cuestiones.
En primer lugar, hemos hecho
una pequeña trampa. Sí,
la criminalidad en Alemania ha crecido,
pero seguimos hablando de un país europeo.
Las cifras que reporta Berlín en materia
de robos u homicidios son sumamente bajas
en comparación al resto del mundo. Seguimos
hablando de un país razonablemente seguro.
Nada que ver con los datos de Estados
Unidos, América Latina o, incluso, Canadá.
Por ejemplo, Alemania reporta una tasa de
homicidios de 0,76 personas por cada 100.000
habitantes. Y eso no es nada. Esta cifra es
todo un sueño para otros países como EE. UU.,
que reporta un nivel de 6,81 homicidios por
100 mil habitantes. Casi 10 veces más. Y
no hablemos ya de America Latina
cuyo dato en 2021 fue de 19,91.
Y aunque en otras rúbricas criminales
las diferencias son más pequeñas,
lo cierto es que Alemania sigue siendo
un país europeo. Es decir, en lo que a
crimen se refiere está a años luz de los países
americanos. ¿Podría eso cambiar? Lo veremos.
En segundo lugar, tenemos que tener claro el
efecto de la pandemia. Su impacto económico
provocó un repunte general de la criminalidad
en todo el mundo: ya sabéis, más desempleo,
menos ingresos, más incertidumbre. Europa
y Alemania no fueron una excepción.
Si comparamos la tasa de homicidios entre
los años 2019 y 2020, Alemania es el sexto
país de la región donde más aumentaron
estos crímenes. Basta con ver el ranking
para ver que los teutones tuvieron
una evolución cercana la de Malta,
Chipre o Portugal, países con las
que Berlín no suele compararse.
Ahora bien, el problema no es que los
homicidios se dispararan durante la pandemia,
sino que en los años siguientes esto no se
revirtió, y justo aquí viene la sorpresa.
Mientras que países como Estonia y Lituania
lograron revertir los incrementos de la
delincuencia, la caída de criminalidad en Alemania
en 2021 no alcanzó a revertir la por completo la
escalada reportada durante la pandemia. Y
luego en 2022 y 2023 lo datos empeoraron.
Y esta es justo la preocupación
de las autoridades alemanas:
a diferencia de sus vecinos, el crimen
en el país está empeorando año tras año
sin que exista una causa económica
clara que respalde esta situación.
Pero, ¿por qué tanto alarmismo si
los datos parecen razonablemente
buenos? Pues como os decimos, tiene
que ver sobre todo con la evolución.
Con la evolución y con el hecho de que
en el caso alemán los homicidios no son
precisamente los crímenes que más han
crecido en los últimos años. Fijaos.
Por ejemplo, en el caso del tráfico
de personas, como podéis ver,
el promedio del periodo 2020-2022 es un 55% más
alto que el reportado en el periodo 2013-2015.
Otro caso similar es de los crímenes sexuales.
Hasta 2016, venían siendo unos 7000 por año,
pero en 2018, estos rozaron los 11.200. Y luego
en 2022 se alcanzó su pico histórico con 11.896.
Es decir, el número de crímenes sexuales
se incrementó un 70% en apenas 5 años.
Luego, otros delitos, como los robos,
tanto los comunes como los agravados
por el uso de la violencia, han
rebotado bruscamente tras 5 años
a la baja. Lo hicieron especialmente tras el
levantamiento de las restricciones sanitarias.
Bien, esta es la situación. Aclarados
estos números volvamos a la pregunta clave:
¿Qué diantres es lo que está provocado esta
repunte de la inseguridad? Pues mucho ojo porque
aquí viene lo más interesante de todo.
(T2: PECERA GRANDE, PECES GORDOS)
¿queréis entender el problema
del crimen en alemania?
pues bien, la oficina federal de investigación
criminal de alemania ha puesto el
foco en el “crimen organizado”.
en concreto, según las autoridades
alemanas, destacan cuatro grandes grupos:
en primer lugar, tenemos al gran talento
local: las bandas de motoristas ilegales.
en alemania existen cerca de 680
asociaciones de moteros con más
de 7800 afiliados. varias de ellas ya han
sido prohibidas en varios países europeos,
y en su especialidad delictiva destacan
los micro delitos de distribución de
drogas, intimidación o asaltos.
en segundo lugar, no podía faltar
la famosa mafia italiana, de la que por cierto,
subimos un vídeo en detalle en visualeconomik.
pues bien, según reportes oficiales,
la delincuencia organizada en alemania
vinculada con la mafia aumentó un 12,5% en 2022.
en este caso se dedican sobre todo a la extorsión,
la distribución de drogas,
y el blanqueo de dinero.
[ya sabéis, lo típico de películas como
casino, que por cierto, es un peliculón]
sea como sea, en el tercer lugar de
nuestra particular lista del crimen
aparece la delincuencia vinculada a
organizaciones rusas y euroasiáticas.
entidades lideradas y gestionadas desde
los países de la antigua órbita soviética.
y finalmente, en cuarto lugar, tenemos a los
clanes sirios y libaneses cuya presencia se
ha incrementado en los últimos años.
en general, las mayores actividades
delictivas que todos estos grupos en el
tráfico de drogas y crimen financiero.
pero amigos, es justo aquí dónde
llegamos al tema más espinoso de todos:
la inmigración. como seguramente ya sabéis,
alemania ha sido uno de los grandes
partidarios de acoger refugiados en europa.
así que seguramente muchos estéis atacando cabos:
inmigración, refugiados…
efectivamente: delincuencia, ¿verdad?
pues… esperad un momento porque en este
caso los datos no parecen ir por ahí.
en su conjunto, el repunte de
la violencia en alemania parece
estar ligado sobre todo a los grupos criminales.
¿y sabéis qué? de las 7.200
personas detenidas en 2022 bajo
la sospecha de participar en organizaciones
criminales, apenas 750 fueron inmigrantes.
es decir, solo 1 de cada 10 detenidos
por crimen organizado son inmigrantes,
un porcentaje muy inferior al peso que
la propia inmigración tiene en alemania.
y a ver, es evidente que la llegada de millones
de personas de bajos recursos y de países con
culturas muy diferentes ha influido en la comisión
de delitos más allá del crimen organizado.
Sin embargo, el gran repunte, el promovido
por los grupos criminales, está dirigido
fundamentalmente por alemanes o por personas que
llegaron al país hace mucho, muchísimo tiempo.
y eso no es todo. otra característica importante
es que todas estas organizaciones es que han
tejido sus redes criminales a lo
largo y ancho del viejo continente,
tienen una estrecha relación con
sus colegas de holanda y españa,
lugares con acceso marítimo
susceptible al tráfico de drogas.
en este sentido, holanda es uno de los casos
que más preocupa a las autoridades alemanas,
la entienden como una macropuerta de entrada para
el tráfico de drogas y fuertes presiones sobre
el sistema judicial. y claro tienen miedo que
esa situación se extienda a la propia alemania.
amigos, llegados a este punto, queda
claro que los problemas de criminalidad
a los que enfrenta alemania son bastantes
particulares. no tienen tanto que ver con
la marginalidad económica, la pobreza o
la debilidad institucional - que suelen
ser los ingredientes habituales
- sino que el territorio teutón
se está convirtiendo en la base operativa
de varios peces gordos del crimen europeo.
Ahora bien, ¿qué está haciendo el
Estado alemán para revertir esta
situación? Mucho diagnóstico pero ¿Quién
será capaz de ponerle el cascabel al gato?
Pues atención, porque en Berlín parece que hay
más dudas que certezas sobre
como enfrentara este problema.
(T3: ¿UN ELEFANTE EN LA HABITACIÓN?)
De momento, el diagnóstico de las
autoridades alemanas sobre el repunte
criminal es, por decirlo de alguna forma,
bastante reservado. En primer lugar, los
portavoces de los cuerpos de seguridad estiman
que las estadísticas actuales son difíciles de
comparar debido a todos los cambios en los hábitos
sociales que se han producido tras la pandemia.
(C4 “Las cifras de casos registradas en 2022 son
comparables a las de 2019, el último año
antes de la pandemia. Esto relativiza el
fuerte aumento con respecto a 2021 (…)
Es probable que una de las principales
razones del aumento del número de casos sea la
supresión de las restricciones impuestas por
el coronavirus y la consiguiente vuelta
a la normalidad de la vida pública. Más
libertad recuperada significa también más
oportunidades para que los delincuentes
cometan delitos.” Holger Münch, director
de la Bundeskriminalamt (Oficina Federal
de Investigación Criminal de Alemania)
¿El problema? Que esto no parece más
que una excusa.
Porque veréis, sí, la vuelta a la normalidad
ha permitido que se vuelvan a perpetrar muchos
delitos, pero eso explicaría el regreso a
los niveles de 2019 como mucho. Sin embargo,
la evolución ha superado con creces ese
nivel previo a la pandemia. Por tanto,
eso no parece una explicación razonable.
Si excluimos la tasa de homicidios,
prácticamente todos los demás delitos han
crecido considerablemente respecto a 2019.
Y a eso tenemos que sumarle que muchos delitos
ya estaban en franco crecimiento desde 2018.
Así pues la explicación del gobierno alemán
no parece sino una cortina de humo: utilizar
la pandemia para dar patada para adelante e
intentar camuflar una deriva muy negativa.
Tal y como hemos visto, el mayor
problema no tiene que ver con la
pandemia sino con la consolidación de un
montón de organizaciones criminales en
Alemania. Eso podría hacer que las tasas de
crimen no mejorasen proximamente. Es decir,
que si no se hace nada el actual brote
podría haber llegado para quedarse.
Como ya hemos visto antes, desde el año 2020
operan al menos 100 organizaciones más de las
que había antes de la pandemia. Esto es lo que
explica un 2023 marcado por noticias como estas:
(3 de mayo de 2023: Alemania e Italia
reprimen con redadas y detenciones
a la mafia italiana. AP News)
(29 de junio de 2023: Austria
se incauta de un gran alijo de armas en una redada
contra moteros de extrema derecha. DW)
N8 (26 septiembre, 2023: Absueltos 13
acusados en el juicio a Hells Angels y penas
de hasta dos años para otros 32. El Espanol)
Así que ya lo veis, los cuerpos de
seguridad alemanes están ni más ni
menos que ante su mayor desafío
desde la reunificación del país.
Dicho esto la pregunta es: ¿Crees
que estas organizaciones criminales
en Alemania han llegado para quedarse?
¿Cómo te enfrentas tu a este problema?
Déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y abramos debate.
Y hora si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like
y suscribiros a este canal si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho
[Y recordad, con el código “POLITIK” acabado
en “K” podréis disfrutar de HASTA SEIS meses
extra totalmente gratis con Surfshark. El
link, como siempre, en la descripción.]
Un saludo y hasta la próxima
Gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.